au lendemain de beuvry pour simon le
jeune historien ne sait pas où il est
mais le voilà interne est monté par le
collectif thermos la grande valse
brillante est une pièce de drago yanchak
écrite en 1985 il s'agit de d'un
établissement
on va dire lambda
dans un premier temps et donc d'un
système qui fonctionne avec différentes
différentes fonctions emblématiques de
l'ordre du politique du religieux et à
l'intérieur de ce système il ya des
rouages
qui vont qui vont se remettre a déraillé
pour le bien ou pour le mal de
l'ensemble de l'ensemble du groupe
humain qu'ils y regarder c'est un cas
difficile
une pièce encore d'actualité où le
public et les artistes font un tout un
trois fronts pour que l'action soit
partout la mise en scène veut faire
réagir et n'essayaient pas de
commandites quatrième mur dans la mesure
où si je pose cette interrogation la
main aujourd'hui sur ce plateau
c'est forcément une c'est forcément une
interrogation et une situation qui me
dérange
ça veut dire que moi je peux pas rester
confortablement assis dans mon fauteuil
à regarder les choses comme si jean zay
par moi même partie donc moi je vais
être moi-même mal à l'aise en fait de me
dire waouh mais en fait là quelqu'un qui
est en train de se faire humilier devant
moi et je bouge pas et je bouge pas
parce que je suis spectatrice huit
comédiens sur scène mais 19 personnages
pour dénoncer une violence du pouvoir
la grande valse brillante et pour la
première fois créé en france